what is going on there citizens the reject
Nation Greg and Sally are returning for a
sequel reaction to I wanted to say this smoother
it did not go as according to plan Pitch Perfect
2 is what we want to watch today Pitch Perfect
Two now last time Sally was visiting California
she's back in the heart of NYC right now um
you know so she can't be here but she's here
doing what Mary Jane does best you and Mary
Jane does best guys go check out the trailer
for her Mary Jane short film she is hard at
work plugging away at the editing system whipping
other people into shape to get it done go
ahead support it it's the way to go about
life Sally are you excited for Pitch Perfect
2. I don't think anyone is as excited as you
are guys Greg is so hyped for this I've never
seen he's more excited about this than like
John Wick yeah okay a little bit more sad
about this than actually having neck Keanu
Reeves I'm more excited for this than anything
else yes that's right guys you know what to
do be a perfect reject by leaving a like that
mean the world also uh subscribe and click
that notification Bell notify when our reaction
for Pitch Perfect 3 is that we gotta complete
the trilogy don't we Sally don't we yes we
do yep full trilogy
and also massive thank you to all who followed
our patreon via the first Pitch Perfect movie
um as always full-length Reaction watch logs
where you sync up with your own copy it Pitch
Perfect 2 available for a super sexy rejects
exclusively however we do cover stuff exclusively
over there as well all right salamander you
ready to kick in action or whatever the phrase
is um so ready let's do it
[Music] should we do vocal warm-ups too red
leather yellow leather
[Applause]
than sitting here to my left is Gail labrinathy
mccadden Fine Burger this one's gonna stick
John well you saved the Jew for last
didn't she direct this one I think so now
here they are performing for the president
of the United States on his birthday wow that's
actually Obama and Michelle Obama what
[Music]
oh my God [Music] Rebecca Mitchell leader
of the group look at these sequins she's already
dancing Becca's the official leader is that
blonde [__] gone yeah I guess so close
having a great time that's insane I'm still
not over that
she may have to do that backflip right back
over the fence into Mexico I think she's going
oh
yes an overweight girl dangling from the ceiling
who hasn't had that dream
[Music]
why do I feel like there's an accident about
to happen I feel it too I'm nervous yep
there's no underwear on we have a Commando
situation
she's turning brace yourself oh no no no no
no no no no nobody wants to
oh that's rough Amy Amy a birthday gift from
Down Under during last night's Night Celebration
chip I'm talking about her she showed her
Virginia to the president I love that guy's
reaction accident although authorities have
ruled out terrorism as a motive
it's a National Disgrace yeah but I'd rather
be in that limo ride home with the president
cut to the real president he'd be like that
[__] was off the hook [Laughter] I like
vaginas Obama impression not vagina
this is terrible it reminds me of feds from
That 70s Show but like a girl version unfortunately
an example must be made it is
suspended what it was an accident like no
one did it on purpose who's in the National
Anthem at the Puppy Bowl a German group of
total professors in other words they're going
to keep their pants on sons of [__] so
basically the Bellas are over
[Laughter] it's so true Sally
Steinfeld are her shoes in this oh yeah I
listen to her music and hands competition
it's not gonna help your case here not at
all what if we win it what if you win it I
feel like
[Music]
what if you win it yeah if we win will you
reinstate us sure what no American team has
ever won oh this is about fighting for America
they're gonna win oh the world
Jesus loves her she wants more
[Music] they don't care what songs they sing
I was gonna say like if this were a real University
like they would be getting me in front of
so bad right now like people be yelling stuff
I know it someone dropped some bass
[Music]
I'll be the burrito [Laughter]
[Applause] [Music]
wow they could never win again they're so
good they are very good that's great news
yes no I can start Monday I'm I would be stupid
what are you thinking I want 100 commitment
and laser focus right great I will see you
Monday now Becca hi Benjamin Applebaum At
Your Service I just have to say you are so
spirited I I just want to put you in a box
and saw you in half nice as a part of a trick
but oh yeah that's right he's a magic he's
the magic boy I was out of context that was
weird dude why do I feel so guilty I'm giving
a lot to the Bellas right it's like three
years of my life yeah back you should not
feel guilty at all about taking your shot
this this is a big deal right yes no Becca
support a boyfriend did he dye his hair it
looks darker
and the age of the internet you're better
off just staying with the acapella group really
you think so are you doing a British accent
yeah I don't know why I don't I don't know
why people who has to help Frank watch YouTube
videos to find the next Justin Bieber oh it's
Keegan Michael Key yay I love him that is
the legendary Snoop Dogg then now he wants
to drop his own cool Christmas album what
I need all hands on deck right now to come
up with ideas on how to make this one stand
out come on Becca let's see why you left the
Bellas she's like we could remix
[Laughter] your mother is Catherine junk word
is she has a five octave vocal range you do
not want to hear that woman doing it with
my dad hey got Anna Kendrick and Haley Steinfeld
in the same movie when tomorrow comes I'll
be on my own being in front of the things
that I don't know when tomorrow comes and
no the road is long I look up to the sky Darkness
all around no that one I'm not I'm still kind
of tinkering with ever so it's not nothing's
really completely said you are my flashlight
would you excuse us for just one second what
are they gonna do I'm nervous for her I don't
think we should decide anything without big
any under my tongue
I didn't hear what she said welcome to the
valley
whoa oh girl stop sorry my first college party
this is acapella only yeah to get prepared
to meet a lot of sexually confuse me [Laughter]
I thought she was with you right Craig slogan
he's so cute the movies are you asking me
out yes
hey Chloe asked where you were why didn't
you tell her she's like locked into the world
right now and I'm looking for the right time
I'll tell her Bumper's back no one cares [Laughter]
I don't know what you're thinking oh Pampa
you shut your face and kiss me [Music] please
just shut up he's doing Gollum my precious
I can't believe we're sisters Chloe texted
me we added a legacy I didn't even know that
was a thing Becca you better get your priorities
straight got work to do and you only got one
shot You Gotta Sing For America and for every
other country in the competition
oh my god oh no [Music] control [Music] s
oh my God yeah they've already started out
with quite a bang
oh this is pretty cool
[Music]
this is good yeah it's like the Terminator
of vocabulary
thought we gonna compete with a group that
size they're so freaking insane yeah their
choreography is crazy [Applause] [Music] [Applause]
[Applause]
I do love this song it's a great song
check you out before the world where we're
going to
it is or is it a fairies she played an elf
and had one movie you are like a troll she
was in trouble oh
she was in trolls and now I really must go
rest my neck it is
I'm gonna use that we're gonna beat DSM at
their own game do what they do important thing
is uh come on
uh why do I feel like Amy's like meaner in
this movie pretty sure they made her up did
they explain what happened to the blonde girl
no was she older than the other ones did she
just graduate and I feel like they should
explain it yeah sexual this time jeez I was
pointers Maybe
exactly where you're gonna put me into the
songs I just have somewhere that I need to
be you know what that felt rude that did feel
like I felt that in my soul yeah I was very
upset [Music]
[Music]
I was not excited there's nothing nothing
special about it yet you know what I mean
hear me out please Dax please remove the sleigh
bells and put in Kalimba um just have him
sing it again the same way who are you nobody
literally nobody I just had a thought what
is the idea she's gonna mess with the beat
a beautiful side we're happy tonight
see I told you she was gonna remix it that's
her thing damn she's actually doing a really
good job [Music]
oh [__] this sounds great yeah good thing
she knows the song Santa Claus
I want this on my Christmas playlist You Belong
With The Palace Greg you are so upset about
this it's great you know yeah I'm like a three-time
Collegiate acapella Champion so wow
Dax turn around right now and and watch this
exchange
[Applause]
that's so funny she did something that was
helpful and now I'm going to reward her but
we've got an idea me too water skis but for
dry land Real Player you know what I'm talking
about brilliant
looks like we've been invited to sing at some
kind of a party well there's just an address
and a password how sexy and mysterious
teeth they're from other people what did she
say can you turn it up I get all my teeth
from other people password fart noise
oh my gosh there's so many famous people in
this yeah this is the big
time holy [__] oh wow the curtains are
soundproof [Music]
the World building in this movie the lore
it's like chocolate expanded first we have
the troublemakers oh is this like a new version
of the riff-off yeah probably like a weird
like culty version
they're back yeah he joined them the Green
Bay Packers what all right all right when
I point to you you sing a song from one of
the categories it's going to appear up there
on the big board you have to meet the beat
Turn the Beat over
but you have to do it Follow the Leader Style
[Laughter]
song
[Music] [Applause] that is not his voice [Music]
[Applause] boots boots [Music]
[Music] can you handle this
I don't think they can handle this I don't
think you're ready
[Music]
[Music] let me
have
it let us have it let the world
how about them Cowboys
[Music] a wheel drive everyone knows this
one yes [Music]
what the hell no he was so hyped couldn't
have done Love Story by Taylor Swift Just
awk appointment
now we're doing Taylor Swift
[Music]
nice getting together you'll go talk to your
friends talk to my friends [Music]
[Laughter] this person dated John Mayer I'm
confused yeah
[Applause] they better have some Cameo at
the end of Tina Turner and John Mayer that
would be funny
oh oh they lose now so they can win later
oh nice nice here we go
to the membrane
[Music] sorry what 90s hip-hop Jam is that
again she has a small palette a 21st century
Jam that's it yeah I wrote it why would she
do that you are sabotaging the Bellas the
Bellas you [__] in light of this embarrassing
and unprofessional information I am forced
to declare [Music] oh but maybe they can win
later by doing Originals thinking like that
song sounded familiar to me it definitely
I think it's a big song
I'm just kidding would you like to have sex
later no no
yeah I did this dead air between us is a good
sign
and what you gave me was more mashups but
if you want to write music producer on your
tax form someday then you've got to have an
original voice look Rebecca what is it Becca
I'm Richard everybody else in here is an intern
you're talented everybody else in here is
talented so what the hell makes you special
you know what I mean he's like the epitome
of how L.A makes you feel show me who you
are as an artist okay oh my God you're calling
Haley write something original yeah talk about
your parents divorce do The Cup Song again
that's a cover no it's not she did it via
a cover
[Music] [Laughter] I feel like Jesse's barely
present in this movie yeah what
fun to know as I enter the rest of my life
oh you're the most talented person that I
know and I've met three of The Wiggles
no way what do I gotta do to get that you
gotta become more Sally become more just more
of a become more become more flash my badge
in front of the president
couple oh wow that's so cute that's rare that
you hook up with a guy and then he wants to
date it doesn't happen you stop sleeping around
Sally I have can you name one bumper and I'll
name one Fat Amy and yours will be bigger
bigger than it'll be cute and we could put
him on our bed that we share he's going too
far but he he has a person is too far you
know
hurt me go back to how things used to be and
go at it or on top of all this expensive food
that I bought are you crying
tied down by anything you know you feel sad
no
nope just for a bunch of old people you got
me so much
is this for the crowd the right crowd um [Music]
who are you performing for I know like what
honestly my senses are overwhelmed here John
you might want to tone down the theatrics
let's hope there are no props like
[Music]
oh my God [Music] now they lit one on fire
oh good heavens
[Music] this is what happens when you send
girls to college is it one of the things
are we the apples burnt to death because you
occupations because he was standing in the
wrong spot no float flipped into me blame
that Minority I'm black gay and a woman [Music]
this legacy's fault me obviously we're not
going to beat docile machine at their game
so we need a new plan like now original music
I think the retreat will be a good thing you
girls need to bond heading into Worlds it'll
be so much fun I don't know no Mom it's bad
or bring her back I'll never get this so low
at Lincoln Center but you're gonna get to
go you girls can win it you just made being
a Bella sounds so amazing this won't be the
end of the Bellas there are three Pitch Perfect
movies yes
oh God no no no no that's not well it looks
great that's really sweet when my hands aren't
covered in in glitter paint do you think maybe
we could try that again let me know I that's
I will you go blow up Lincoln Center
that's right how'd you hear about this place
from yours truly no way oh there she is back
you know I realized that I had an app barking
orders and bending people's will so I made
a career out of it fellas no slouching
great sorrow that I had to watch our once
proud organization become a National Disgrace
you have told lost your Harmony sure you will
be doing everything together until you regain
it then where are we staying
in sync snore in harmony
we're very close but
I feel like they're about to kiss I know I
don't think
[Laughter]
it out can you sing something
[Music] oh my God a poop song
I want that song to play every time I go to
the bathroom he was a famous [Music] trumpet
I guess those live nodes aren't our problem
anymore guess what isn't a problem the lymph
nodes oh yeah
[Music] Grown Ups three [Music] rediscovering
our sound because it feels like we're just
singing songs that would never go in our set
some th down but
all his losses coming up she's having a breakdown
I don't want you guys to fight your Becca
and Chloe together your blow eats and everything
oh well done so legit music producer wants
to hear my word so why would you keep something
like that from us because you're obsessed
you all are this has been my family for seven
years yeah cause you're too scared to leave
oh this is necessary yeah
oh [__] that was kind of scary yeah that
like jump scare that got me
oh my team building program
oh my God I'm sorry
I'm sorry I don't actually know which one
of you is which I'm Jessica
[Laughter]
I stick upside down like a bat she said I
sleep upside down like a bat yeah that's scary
that scared me she's scary you're so good
it's intimidating is to be one of you you
are one of us you pay the registration fee
[Laughter] to move on to graduate it's really
scary it totally seems that way it actually
does seem yeah hahaha
underprivileged children how to sing or I'll
dance exotically whatever offers the most
money [Laughter] after I graduate there's
a chance I will be deported I will try to
re-enter this country but I will probably
die at sea so let's live for tonight yeah
[Music] that's a serious issue yeah how about
no one takes her issues seriously no thank
you I don't know no one knows what she said
okay no she said I just want to travel through
time oh you got it am I good at that
I got my ticket for the long way around the
cup song
[Music]
this looks awesome I got the chills yeah what
a great little campfire moment I'd be living
somewhere like sick like Tulsa or a Little
Rock I'm a professional jelly wrestler for
corporate events [Music] [Laughter]
I need to win back my man
[Applause] [Laughter] that was well done yeah
whatever [Laughter]
I don't want to see you go to her bumper
[Laughter] [Music]
[Laughter]
belong
together [Music] go to her he's still upset
close your eyes
the way you did that was so good [Music] [Laughter]
I hear your voice inside me I see your face
[Music] [Laughter]
there we go bump in the middle of the night
just skipping their way to a whole career
yeah I don't like it what it is is I don't
I don't like it would can do what I can do
you know in a manner of speaking it's threatening
[Laughter]
he's real for that
my girls are all grown up Sally does that
mean like a lot of them aren't even in the
third one is it like a different cast yeah
they're like old in the third one right like
old women it's in the future they're like
we must come together
yes singing Kumbaya does making one last attempt
to repair a damaged Legacy can they do it
John realistically absolutely not those girls
are dead to me [Laughter] well you have them
as your screen saver what are you doing here
oh yes you know anything to support the ballots
I love you I have something for you
oh what way to go guy you took all of Jesse's
screen time yeah yeah where is he
[Music] this is cool
oh that's the Pentatonix right there that
was awesome oh [__] good cat Sally ah
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] there they are
that's Pentatonix that's cool they actually
got them at Cameo yeah I've seen them live
they're incredible
[Music] also a great song [Music]
they do have a great sale yeah that's that's
pretty good imagine having to watch her competition
like before going on
[Music] sounds truly electronic
that was a great transition
[Music]
yeah that shit's awesome yeah yeah one thing
it's missing is real fire why would you watch
them that watching someone else audition for
your role and kill it
oh wow that's good how are they going to top
it if the Bellas of old show up tonight this
could be the most significant conflict between
America and Germany in history oh my God yes
we're gonna show them who we are a bunch of
ethnically diverse for the most part feminine
amazing what are their outfits though Greg
hey it's giving Ellen DeGeneres hey hey just
told Walmart herself they hold on I can't
the suspense don't go out there invest why
are you going out there in beds
okay
okay now that's cool yeah
they're like playing an advanced version of
patty cake
[Music] [Applause]
bring it on baby all your friends
[Music]
now this is great [Music] awesome when tomorrow
comes
[Music]
is it possible the pardon Bellas are doing
an original song God damn right um [Music]
wow that both chills Galore oh they're like
pass Bellas oh is the mom there I hope so
that's what I was thinking
[Music] uh they're uniting everyone with their
music America unites everyone [Music] yeah
they keep saying it's an original song but
I know this song well it actually played on
the radio after this movie oh is it from this
movie yeah I think so yeah nice they didn't
want it I
forever and then nothing weird happens after
that yes every villain was Chris in the house
by sliding down the staircase don't worry
I'll show you behold
[Music]
uh I don't want to break my neck all right
I'm ready but I also want to do that
Pitch Perfect dose to the second it's suck
dick
yes I love him
oh no way oh my God [Music]
camping you down [Music] [Applause] [Music]
[Laughter] [Music]
now that's his song right [Applause] [Music]
no no why wow I was thinking of John Legend
that's not John Legend Adam it's Adam Levine
and Adam DeVine that's the joke his name's
Adam DeVine and that's Adam Levine and they
get [Music] [Applause] hell yeah
[Applause] what's your name brother I don't
even know right now please just under no circumstances
choose me for your coach you're interesting
and I can work with interesting okay you got
Christina [Applause] [Music] [Applause]
oh I said hey Amy oh yeah they definitely
uh shot that problem during one of the real
shows more than likely that would be cool
that's so awesome yeah that's a mid credit
scene but yeah that was the joke like he so
his name is Adam DeVine and he gets mixed
up with Adam Levine all the time so it was
so funny to see them in something together
I want to see if Pitch Perfect 2 made money
or Pitch Perfect okay I know a song made money
my God I did hear that song on the radio the
flashlight song it's perfect one only made
115 million worldwide on a budget of 17 million
so it did really well okay it's perfect too
holy [__] Pitch Perfect 2 made 287 million
dollars worldwide off of a 29 million dollar
budget what so the first one was like a hit
and the second one was like a massive hit
damn wow good for them yeah I mean for it
to be I mean I guess it is based off a book
but still for it to be like you know I don't
think the book had anything to do with it
I was gonna say for an original idea for Hollywood
that's like very different like that's a big
accomplishment yeah they they didn't even
double their budget they they went a little
under their budget a lot like wow yeah they
added like 10 more million dollars and they
had way more cameos in this movie too it was
just shocking it's a cultural phenomenon Sally
good for them for doing an original idea instead
of remaking something what a blast hold on
we just got waited out just a couple more
minutes okay I want this to be organized and
structured
get your thoughts in order while we wait for
a post-credits scene these movies are so fun
they are fun have you ever seen the movie
music lyrics no oh is that the uh Hugh Grant
movie yes yeah I've seen I saw that uh when
it first came out all I remember is the ending
have you seen the movie sing Street my favorite
movies and it's got an amazing soundtrack
I've never seen sing Street you have to see
sing Street it's so it's such an inspiring
movie I love it so much I don't know that
movie yeah it's actually really popular in
the I actually heard the soundtrack first
fell in love with the soundtrack realized
it was from a movie watched the movie and
was like Blown Away it was so good bastards
why do I care to sit through credits show
my appreciation for people all right Sally
I'll let you kick it off kick it off deer
do it do the kicking off you there hello yeah
wait that was a lot um it was actually it's
so hard to do sequels and I think this one
definitely delivered it brought everything
it could
it was a little slow though for me and like
the first not first half but like first quarter
or third of it I think some things were it
was like slow I don't know why but then I
feel like once once I got to the camp you
know and we got to see I forget her name the
blonde come back that was a great moment I
feel like from then on the pacing was great
for some reason like the beginning was a little
slow for me but I think the yeah I mean I
I still I thought this movie was a I still
had a lot of fun watching it I don't think
it's as focused as the first one is that's
a great it's a great way to put what I was
thinking your focus isn't good because like
you know you're you're gonna get to the finale
uh at the at the at the concert with the worlds
but yeah um it didn't I guess it didn't feel
like it it was as uh important or mattered
as much as the movie would would try to tell
you it does like this I guess the stakes felt
like bigger in the first movie there was more
of an underdog and because of that um because
yeah they were they were a little bit divided
between like her music producing career and
the other subplots and our main character
cared more about the music producing side
and then the being part of the Bellas and
and I think because of that even though the
music producing side of the story ended up
uh like as the movie kept going yeah as the
movie went it kept getting better um I could
see how it's not as strong but it's still
it's still more it's still really fun I thought
like from beginning to end and everyone still
brought their a game and uh it is it would
be hard to do a sequel to not just make it
repetitive too right and so I appreciate that
they took it in directions that allowed for
it to be you know like some familiarity stuff
of course some beats familiar familiar beats
but they didn't tell the same story again
and it was dealing with like moving on and
growing up in like one last hurray even though
there's a third one but you know like what
else uh and and I liked all the other subplots
as well the the the part and this is where
the the the Divide for Meek would sometimes
happen with some of the music stuff was in
the in the fir I'm talking specifically about
the sound mixing and and the first one it
really felt like they were singing in your
ears yeah I felt like they were singing when
they were filming you know look like they
were like pointing a camera and they were
just capturing them while they were singing
yeah this one felt way more produced yeah
it felt like there was record it was recording
and they were like uh adding it on top of
you know I would be more aware of it this
time around um but then because of that it
allowed you to get away with some moments
that really were funny and weren't like when
Fat Amy is on the on the canoe and and and
she's singing that was so funny and she's
singing a bumper like that's hilarious and
and it felt real when they were on stage at
the very end it felt real uh when they were
singing around the campfire like that felt
real but some of the other stuff prior it
did feel like it doesn't it does it doesn't
seem as real anymore I'm aware that this is
like a recording and you're mixing it in now
whereas before I wasn't aware of it um but
it's still it is still I like don't get me
wrong I still I still really enjoyed it I
still really want to watch it yeah like yeah
I I could say like by comparison like yeah
the first one's a better movie but but yeah
but I still really thought this was a great
time and and like them thought like ah my
girls I love them you know and I wanna I wanna
watch the third one still I really do so I
wouldn't I wouldn't deny that but yeah there
was the folk the focus wasn't as um cohesively
as you're right it was kind of all over the
place I feel like uh it it finally did kind
of uh coalescence towards the end um and and
it found its focus towards and obviously it
had to with the championship um you know for
me sequels are always so hard so anytime I
watch a sequel of a hit movie my my standards
and my expectations are already so low because
I know that most of the time they can never
really uh top the first one unless the second
one is so different that it feels like its
own movie but is still somehow true to the
original sort of like message I guess so this
one there were a lot of repetitive type moments
that they did but they definitely did a good
job of trying to like make them different
in a way like for example The Sing-Off that
they had in the beginning you're in the first
one you're right like that one it actually
sounded like they were a real acapella a real
acapella groups battling each other I feel
like with this one they definitely brought
it up a notch when they were at that dude's
random party that whole thing was weird but
like also uh like it didn't make sense but
also I I enjoyed watching it especially with
the Green Bay Packers that that sent me um
but that one definitely like sounded more
like not realistic you know what I mean but
um and then I I don't know a few things I
thought Snoop Dogg would come back
yeah so that would have been nice I also think
like maybe even kind of make it a little more
cohesive I feel like it would be cool if there
had been like some sort of scene at the end
where like that song had been a hit and maybe
she got a record deal or like they got a record
deal or something from that um because I feel
like then the recording studio thing didn't
fully um makes sense but there was just so
much like uh conflict I feel like for like
no reason you know what I mean like and sometimes
they're like how can we add conflict and sometimes
the which conflict to care about like when
they were going on the retreat and saying
like we need to go back in Harmony and stuff
I guess I didn't register that was a problem
until like they did that performance at the
very uh when when everything went to [__]
and people caught on fire I was like okay
I guess this is a problem and this is maybe
what the movie should have been about um yeah
yeah that's a good point that's a good point
I feel like the overall like to me I feel
like with what you were saying and explaining
we were kind of figuring it out because I
knew that there was something kind of like
missing with the story that just like there
wasn't a through line you know what I mean
it was it found it at the end or like kind
of in the middle but it would have been cool
if that was more established in the beginning
that they just weren't getting along or maybe
not on the same page with things well yeah
I think with with Becca they definitely try
to do that but I feel like everyone else was
stole fine and until it wasn't and you're
like wait what yeah and the first movie um
like like I think this movie is is really
saved by like it still wears it's hard on
its sleeve and it it still has a lot of great
music and the performances are still a lot
of fun and there's like I like the development
of the relationship with fat Amy and bumper
a lot um I think Haley Steinfeld is a really
solid addition um I liked everything with
Ben Platt and Haley Steinfeld that was really
that was really endearing to give him I brought
a lot of heart to it like those two characters
brought a lot of heart to it yeah um which
reminded me of the first one was Becca and
Jesse which Jesse where were you bro yeah
and I and I think um you know like the I think
the arc for Becca in the first one is just
so much stronger of someone who she was also
like happier in the first I feel like in this
one she just was like mad the whole time or
like annoyed the whole time you know what
I mean well that's what I mean is it the the
ending competition didn't hold as much weight
because it it felt like our main character
didn't really care and that's what the hard
part about doing a sequel like this is like
yeah you know you can't go like darker you
can't go bigger and darker with a sequel like
this you and you don't want to just repeat
the plot of the first one they're already
Champions um so yeah like I can see why I
mean I heard this as I saw in our comments
like people were like it's not as it's not
as strong um but God damn you know like I
I'll admit though it's still so [__] Charming
to me I still thought it was so true and I
think the cast is still so so great together
and they're they're just some truly funny
moments I I love it still had yeah it saw
some great scenes it still had some really
awesome cameos that we weren't expecting that
on it it made it feel a little more real like
see you know the all the newscaster Clips
in the beginning and the voice part got me
like like it was like that the production
of it so well done and I like the I like the
variety of all the performers they had and
as much as they make like offensive jokes
they'd really do do like a celebration of
cultures uh at the very end which I thought
was fun because they they do a lot of offensive
jokes um yet they they like they're like oh
no we'll really celebrate everyone at the
end though and I thought that was really touching
um yeah yeah and I don't know uh I don't know
what you do for a third one either um but
because they've done their own Champion they've
done their own like uh what was that like
state competition and then they did like the
country competition and then now they've done
the world competition so at that point I I
feel like the only thing they could do then
is kind of do a Pentatonix deal where it's
like they got a record deal and now they have
to like tour you know yeah and that or be
a part of a tour where now they're maybe they're
not gonna get along with other musicians or
other singers on the tour like that's the
only thing I can like think of plot wise that
could be a sequel so yeah true true um yeah
I mean overall still had a great time I I
I still feel like the I don't know I I wouldn't
it didn't really go slow for me it was just
a little bit not as strong a lot of fruit
wasn't as strong for me in the first half
but then yeah things really started to get
better in the last half for me uh yeah overall
and that's not to say the first half doesn't
have like plenty of moments that I still really
enjoyed but yeah it's not a it's a little
a little it works on Clumsy it kind of stumbly
a little bit though um a little yeah it wasn't
it didn't flow for me until I would say they
can't the camp part and on like that that
flowed way better than before um I felt like
it was like trying to find its way and then
it found its way I think he was trying to
find its comedy voice again like well yeah
that was the other thing the comedy for me
like the first one I think is like funnier
this one had diff had funny moments of that
like it was like a different style of comedy
in a lot of areas in this movie so maybe it
was just kind of keeping up with the times
because I feel like um I don't know what the
what was the gap on these two movies uh I
think like two three years something like
that okay that's not bad but I didn't like
their outfits that's one thing I'm like guys
yeah that for the world comp what you know
what would have been cool though actually
if they didn't win the world championship
um but they but they learned
no I don't know yeah yeah and um because yeah
like the at the end of the day is cool it
was like the German guy's music actually sounded
they seemed like they were out of a sketch
you know they were so good in this movie they
were a standout for sure it's like if the
villains the villains technically like I felt
like were were stronger in this movie well
they well I'm a little bit on a divide there
because I feel like the I feel like for me
personally I feel like the the you know it's
like the ones before they had to be were the
um what are they called the troublemakers
um yeah they had to beat them uh but you got
to know them you know you really got and they
felt like they felt like real people whereas
the I mean I don't know these were charactery
these are these are the top yeah they were
sketches you know um they were sketches but
they were still fun and they did seem like
they'd be really hard to beat in fact I'll
say like as much as I liked I like I loved
the last performance by the palace I was like
looks like the German people did way better
obviously I wasn't gonna say it I wasn't gonna
say it I was like is Greg because that's where
I was getting at I was like it kind of would
have been good if if the Germans won because
no it would have been made a little more sense
um yeah their performance was just so crazy
and awesome and they sound like an elephant
like they really sound like the instruments
you know and and yeah that was nuts um but
they I mean I really I really love I I really
love the performance that the Bellas did at
the same time I was like I don't feel like
the other ones really brought the house down
I guess no but I guess it was like uniting
you know true yeah I don't know but yeah I
feel like it would have been okay if the other
one it's won I don't think it would have made
the ending any less powerful for the fellas
you know yeah like you win uh you win the
respect back of the people still and you win
the respect of the Germans learn the meaning
of friendships yeah stuff like that nice nice
stuff nice crap like that you know um but
overall yeah I had a great time um I still
I still really wanna I I'm like I'm dead serious
I still really want to watch a third one like
yeah I just like I like I just like hanging
out with these people you know that's the
thing it's like I like hanging I like hanging
out with them and I like being in the world
and the time passes by that's probably why
they did so well because people probably like
I can understand why a movie like this people
would go see in theaters because it is like
hanging out with friends uh in an intimate
setting like on a screen um it's like the
same feeling like you go to a concert multiple
times to see like the same artist it's because
you're kind of just there hanging out with
them and music's involved and I feel like
this has the same sort of feel as like you
go into a concert and you feel like you know
them because you've watched them yeah and
then and the music Renditions are always great
which is the main thing you show up for with
these but um yes but you lace it together
with a good enough screenplay and um this
this was solid enough to me I hope Pitch Perfect
3 is better I I wait to see the Rotten Tomatoes
I don't know I feel like it feels like it
would be a really upheaval battle to do no
I I saw a comment that said the third one
was like the worst one I mean I know I'm nervous
well let's see Pitch Perfect one has an 81
critic score and an 83 audience score nice
Pitch Perfect Two I don't know how to give
that movie like 100 I was like that one's
perfect uh Pitch Perfect Two okay on both
ends it's 65 and 64. so definitely went down
with audiences as well um I don't want to
look up three because I feel like that'll
impact oh you're right it would influence
yeah okay you're right I won't either I'm
gonna avoid three for now and then wait to
wait to look it up after like I didn't know
what Pitch Perfect 2 was until right now um
but that's good to know either way alrighty
guys well thank you so much for being here
uh still really liked it not as much as the
first one but still really enjoyed the hell
out of it and I'm excited I'm still excited
to watch Parker because I just love being
in this world it's one of those one of those
first like there are some franchises where
the first one Remains the best but I still
love the franchise overall you know you know
it just search me as like that kind of experience
um leave your thoughts down below what you
think of Pitch Perfect Two uh you can subscribe
leave a like and also follow Sally on her
YouTube channel check out her trailer for
The Mary Jane thing that she has been Mary
Jane sure Phil that she's been working her
ass off on and and the Vlog will be out by
the time this comes out so Greg is in it oh
yes sweet and you are in the Vlog so you get
to see a little if you want to see Greg for
like a split second in the film go to my channel
a little sneak peek yeah it was massive someone
asked if you if you played Uncle Ben I could
play Uncle Ben but it was just so funny they
were like is he Uncle Ben Peter the great
power comes great responsibility all right
boom with great shot prayer great power it
was great responsibility you're not my dad
a Petro with a good act of power create the
responsibility I feel like I feel like the
Italian accent's a little much the New York
you need the New York Italian like I'm walking
yo Peter with great power here comes great
responsibility you son of a [__] yo
all right we're done okay we're ending this
now all right we have to recast you now it's
done alrighty guys we'll see you all soon
thanks for bearing huh bye
foreign